the woke mind virus is basically a form
of cultural Marxism at the end of the
day it's an attack on the truth and
because it's a war on truth I think we
have no choice but to wage a war on woke
woke woke woke Florida is where woke
goes to die we will end woke the most
important thing to understand about
so-called cultural Marxism is that it
essentially does not exist and what I
mean by that is
Marxism focuses on economic structures
and class struggle that's the first
thing to understand it doesn't actually
focus on cultural or social issues
although Marxism does acknowledge that
culture and Society will be shaped by
the economic system that's number one so
even the term doesn't really make sense
secondly the entire emergence of the
term cultural Marxism came from a
misinterpretation of actual Marxism
that's number two and the number three
there's also no marxists in the United
States